[Applause]  hey  no wonder richard williams was so  stressed his joke was squished  where's regina  [Applause]  what the hell  you were supposed to be venus  i know i am venus as tammy faye  i'm sorry all right i i'm just tammy  faye i always wanted to play a crazy  white lady  hi  guys well where's amy amy supposed to be  serena i'm right here wait what the hell  what are you doing this was not the plan  what we're supposed to dress them as our  favorite movie right all right you know  what no that's not what we were doing  you know what i had with y'all i'm  thrilled you know what i saved a lot  like a lot  what wait we're sorry daddy please okay  yeah me  okay i do not know how to get down so  somebody could maybe  come  you